iniziamo da molto lontano in una stanza
in sicilia con una televisione
perennemente spenta ed un uomo dai
capelli color argento che teneva sulle
ginocchia una bambina
la bambina ascoltava con gli occhi
sgranati ogni sua singola parola quella
bambina
l'avrete già capito dall'accento ero io
e quell'uomo era mio nonno gino un uomo
colto geniale ogni giorno intento
inventarne una nuova mio nonno però non
era solo un inventore lui aveva la
passione per la storia e non mi
raccontava le favole di biancaneve e di
cappuccetto rosso
lui mi raccontava delle grandi ceste roy
che dell'iliade e dell'odissea alle
elementari non sapevo nulla della bella
addormentata nel bosco ma sapevo tutto
nella bellissima elena di [ __ ] e di
ulisse che legato a un albero
resiste al canto delle sirene a ulisse
rimasi particolarmente affezionata
perché da lui ho imparato essere
visionaria a guardare oltre le colonne
d'ercole a cercare una luce in mezzo al
buio ed orissa ho preso anche la prima
legge della resilienza l'ostinazione se
pensi che qualcosa sia giusto continui a
farlo se hai un sogno
sei tu il primo che si deve impegnare eh
si io sono cresciuta così con i valori
della creatività e del lavoro da una
parte ei valori dei grandi eroi
dall'altra la mia infanzia e la mia
giovinezza scorrono più o meno
tranquilla anche se essere la figlia dei
primi genitori divorziati in una città
della sicilia degli anni 80
non rende certo il mio quotidiano
semplicissimo
eppure di quel periodo molto intenso io
ricordo alla fine una sola frase di mia
nonna francesca nella diversità non c'è
pena c'è solo vantaggio a 18 anni mi
trasferì a palermo per frequentare
ingegnere elettronica quella che i tempi
pensavo fosse la prosecuzione naturale
dei miei studi col tempo però è anche
grazie a qualche scarso risultato mi
accorsi che quella non era la scelta
giusta per me era la scelta che qualcun
altro aveva fatto per me ci misi due
anni per metabolizzare quello che adesso
reputo un piccolo fallimento e mi
iscrisse all'accademia di belle arti
una scelta molto sofferta e mia madre
certo non me l'ha resa più semplice non
ti permetterà di fare l'ha mantenuta per
altri cinque anni per poi andare
elemosinare ma io avevo già preso la mia
decisione
quindi scelsi di filtrare le paure di
mia madre per trovare soluzioni
anticipare gli ostacoli
chiesi ed ottenni ogni anno una borsa di
studio d'estate in più me ne andavo a
lavorare e la sera sotto esame
ovviamente non si dormiva mai fu un
periodo che al sud chiamiamo pesante che
però mi regalò la seconda legge della
resilienza il impara a prevenire gli
ostacoli grazie a chi non crede in te e
raccogli energia da chi crede in te gli
anni dell'accademia proseguono in
maniera molto soddisfacente tra i 30 e
lode è una relazione che va a gonfie
vele fino a quando però la differenza di
visione sul futuro non si manifesta
anche nella mia coppia felice
iniziò un periodo buio tutto quello per
cui avevo lavorato tutto quello in cui
credevo non aveva più senso
a giudicare dai vostri sguardi dall'età
media in sala mi sa che vi ricordiate
tutti quanto facciamo nella fine del
primo grande amore per me fu un periodo
di nichilismo fino a quando un piccolo
istinto di rivolo di sopravvivenza buste
mediamente francesca o continui così
sulla via del nichilismo e diventi di
pietro o semi di qualcosa io scelsi di
seminare chiesi di andare in erasmus e
chiesi ed ottenni di andare in germania
la patria dei filosofi ed e matematici
quando arriva in terra tedesca vestita
come totò ne riduce di russia appesi la
terza in regola della resilienza quando
si è smarrito to semina prima o poi la
vita ti riderà dietro un frutto
la germania mi piacque talmente tanto
che decisi di rimanere anche dopo
l'erasmus mi iscrisse al corso in arte e
spazio pubblico
avevo finalmente trovato un corso che mi
insegnava a fare arte per le persone
comuni e non per i galleristi o per i
musei in classe eravamo 20 persone
artisti di qualsiasi genere pittori
scultori ma anche giornalisti filosofi
architetti e provenivano da diversi
paesi del mondo
dovetti quindi confrontarmi col tema
dell'intercultura qualcosa che oggi in
italia si conosce ma i tempi non si
conosceva per niente e io mi appassionai
così tanto il tema dell'intercultura che
decisi di approfondirlo e fece anche
diversi viaggi studio parigi londra
budapest versioni in cina grazie a tutti
questi viaggi ho potuto conoscere
centinaia di storie alcuna letto solo
per pochi secondi negli occhi di un
mendicante e grazie a queste storie o
poteva prendere un'altra legge della
resilienza guarda sempre chi sta peggio
di te per poter ritrovare la felicità in
quello che già hai e guarda sempre chi
sta meglio di te per trovare la spinta
verso quello che vuoi ancora ottenere
dopo otto anni in germania
raccolsi tutta la mia esperienza in un
bagaglio ma lo porta in italia mi
iscrissi al master in comunicazione
economica interculturale per sfruttare
il tedesco trova il lavoro dentro una
multinazionale furono sei anni di
osservatorio privilegiato dentro le
dinamiche aziendali però furono anche
sei anni costellati di conflitti
riunioni lunghe tediose e soprattutto
sterili la sera tornava a casa così
stanca così esausta che non avevo più
energia per fare arte non avevo più
energie per i miei sogni ma non avevo
neanche energia per incontrare un amico
vedere
difatti avevo quello che quasi tutti gli
italiani desiderano il famoso posto
fisso
però per me era diventato un incubo
dovevo scegliere o continuavo sulla
strada che tutti si aspettavano per
seguissi la carriera e la sicurezza
economica o mi lanciavo in un progetto
del tutto innovativo commenta innovativo
che al tempo non era chiaro che a me
stessa decisi di licenziarmi e punta e
tutte le energie su di me in maniera
metodica feci un elenco di tutto quello
che sapevo fare è un elenco di tutto
quello che mi piaceva fare e mi rendeva
felice dall'intersezione di questi due
elenchi prendo qualcosa che possa
servire anche agli altri e dopo otto
mesi di lavoro nasce talento umano un
progetto di formazione innovativo in
italia il mio progetto al centro il
benessere della persona e la scuola di
dibattito nella scuola di dibattito e
gli insegni a dividere il contenuto
razionale da quella emozionale e non una
conversazione conflittuale insegno a
portare avanti le proprie ragioni
prima di attaccare quelle dell'altro
insegno a convincere l'altro invece che
vincere sull'altro
il mio metodo si fonda dal punto di
vista teorico sulla filosofia del
linguaggio di che vergia e il dialogo
strategico di giorgio nardone ovvero sul
concetto che il linguaggio non solo
descrive la realtà ma addirittura alla
plasma dal punto di vista pratico mi
fondo sotto masters international ovvero
sul concetto che attraverso la pratica
si acquisiscono delle competenze oggi la
scuola di dibattito non è ancora una
realtà affermata in tutta italia ma io
credo che presto lo diventerà non solo
perché il mio sogno personale ma perché
credo che sia il sogno di tutti voi qui
presenti oggi in sala quello di avere
nella nostra italia persone leader più
preparata a costruire i dialoghi
dibattiti e quindi relazioni piu
efficaci e perché un sogno accompagnato
da progettazione non possono che
diventerà realtà
[Applauso]